[Music]
[Applause]
mark wahlberg actor die hard boston fan
his new film uncharted hits theaters
here in the united states this friday
and he's uh acting with uh tom holland
who is on a roll here and i'll let mark
tell you about the uh the movie joins us
now mark how's morale going today
what's up buddy i'm feeling pretty good
how are you i'm good you're in new york
so you got out you didn't even
experience well you wouldn't have
celebrated the rams winning the
championship would you
no you know i'm happy for i got uh
friends that are on the team i'm happy
for odell
uh i'm certainly happy for for uh aaron
donald and uh
and sam but you know it's one of those
things where i was kind of pulling for
the you know the small market team but i
really didn't have any stress it was one
of the more enjoyable games for me you
know when the patriots aren't in it i'm
a crazy i mean when the patriots are in
it i'm a crazy person so for me it was
it was super relaxed i didn't uh
didn't really it was a concern one way
or the other did you go to the game
i did i went a couple hours early i was
doing some stuff to promote
uncharted so i was there doing some
press had uh some meetings with a bunch
of people i jumped from box to box then
i left after the first quarter i got
home in time to see the halftime show
which i thought was the greatest
halftime show that i had ever seen it
was fantastic uh and then i watched the
rest of the game but i watched at home i
had some friends over my wife had a
little super bowl party it was uh
very enjoyable what did that music mean
to you growing up the halftime show oh
my gosh well i remember
the first time
my brother donny and i were at
interscope records and
dr dre came in with the chronic
and we were there and i had already had
my record deal and they were talking
about whether or not they were going to
do a deal with death row and we heard
the record and just thought it was one
of the best records we've ever heard
it's still one of the best records to
this day
so that music is part of my childhood
but also to see kendrick now who's a new
artist and so talented i thought that he
was um
one of the best highlights of that and
of course mary j blige who's my absolute
favorite mary and i did shows back in 91
for like hot 97 radio and cancun mexico
and stuff so for her to still be killing
it as hard as she is uh it's absolutely
amazing who did you open up for
like that would surprise me
oh we opened up
wow we opened up for a lot of people i
would say the the big shows we were
always doing were like the radio shows
who was like us boys to men you know
mary j blige
it was a long list um you know
oh god
tlc we are all kind of coming up at the
same time so but i opened up for the new
kids i used to get in trouble because i
would do things that were inappropriate
for a younger audience over in europe
and uh i would always get an earful from
uh from my brother wait what were you
doing
is there nudity you know pulling down my
pants cursing you know that sort of
thing i think that was cool
and those days are over right
yeah i mean it depends on the golf
course
and i think the last time you rapped was
when you were on our show five years ago
yes with ella yeah dad
yeah that was a lot of fun ella's coming
a long way by the way she's super mature
now
well behaved thank god lots of prayers
answered there okay but you know you
have that moment where it doesn't matter
if you're famous or not to them you're
like you're an uncool dad
you you embarrass me and you say stupid
things like
but you got to fight through that you
gotta you gotta hold on you say to your
wife
uh when does this end because it it
feels like it goes on a little too long
yeah it doesn't really end although my
sons now are becoming obsessed with golf
and now that we've got real a i could
play and b
we get to go play really cool golf
courses and they're seeing lots of cool
golfers that are actually my friends
that are professional so i got a little
cool factor in the golf in the golf
world with my sons i didn't know that
you love to prank people so much what's
the best prank that you've pulled off
it was probably
on the dan patrick show when i called
pete berg to pretend to be a guy from
louisiana
and we're talking about the little
altercation that happened on the plane
and pete was trying to say that you know
that wasn't really how it happened and
then when he realized it was me uh the
look on his face was classic i remember
like it was yesterday i was in new
orleans i think i was shooting two guns
with denzel i was in my hotel room so
i'm watching him live as i'm calling in
that was that was pretty good that was
up there but when you're acting with
somebody like denzel
do you ever catch yourself going i'm
acting with denzel in the moment
well it's happened a couple of times
whether it be with like denzel jack
nicholson robert duvall but you know
they're they are such great mentors and
they really you know you could either be
with somebody who's going to elevate
your game and you realize that it's it's
to your benefit to just kind of go there
and just do your best uh or you can kind
of not rise to the occasion but you're
only as good as the guy next to you and
to work with guys that are that talented
i always i always get very excited about
that but they know how respectful i am
and that i'm a student of the game and
uh but yeah and then of course i'm also
fearless in trying anything so uh you
know that was those are some of the
greatest experiences that i've had and i
carry those experiences on and try to
share those experiences when working
with young actors like tom holland did
you cry when tom brady announced he was
retiring
no i was just happy for him i was happy
you know for me he done so much for new
england he's done so much for football
you know for us to you know to win that
many championships uh you know six
titles
it's a blessing whatever he wants to do
i'm more than supportive and and and
just uh you know happy for him
i was watching perfect storm it was on
last night and there's there's the scene
when you guys are drowning
now
how do you
how do you act like you're drowning
well you know it's actually it was
pretty helpful in that we were in the
tank and warner brothers you got the
wave machines going the rain and all
that stuff
and there are guys because the shot of
me especially when they're fading away
and i'm supposed to be in the middle of
the ocean
the mark itself is so critical for focus
that you have guys scuba guys under the
water holding my feet
to keep me in position but they don't
realize where the waves are in relation
to where my head is so they're holding
me in that position and when the waves
go up i'm submerged and i'm like trying
to get away and you know swim away
that's your first instinct right it's
the swim but so it was it was pretty
scary that was a pretty sketchy time to
shoot that because i didn't want to mess
up a take wolfgang would would not have
been happy with me or filmmaker but was
there any thought of
like the ending like that you know we
normally have hollywood endings i like
when you have a real ending an ending
that makes you think but you know you
and george clooney die
yeah i mean well it's a true story you
know many many a fisherman has gone out
to provide us the simple pleasures of
eating fish for dinner uh and not come
back especially in the flemish cap and
uh and places like that so you know um
those guys you know they're on the
andrea gale uh they didn't come back
you have this new movie with tom holland
and he's sort of the it guy right now
uh can you give him advice on dealing
with
whatever it is that he's going to deal
with i mean have you been in that moment
that level where it's like whatever you
do whoever you're dating wherever you go
tmz they're all there waiting for you
yeah i mean things have changed quite a
bit with social media since i was his
age but he's had a lot of success in a
very short amount of time but he's he's
comes from a great family he really has
his head on right and he's you know he's
disciplined he he works hard he knows
that this kind of success in big ip like
like spider-man or even uncharted is
very different from you being above the
title on your own an original movie so
he's he's really out there trying to do
great things in between that showcases
talent and ability as an actor and i
think he's gonna have a very long career
explain this movie and how it came up
so this movie actually came up in for me
2009 i just finished the fighter david
o'russell and i attached ourselves to do
uncharted i was playing the role of
nathan drake i have since now aged out
to playing the royal
the elder statesman um but you know i
embraced that it was one of those things
when i did get the call i was a bit
surprised because i'm like all right we
got uncharted going again i hope you're
ready i was like absolutely i'm ready
and i was like who's the other guy
because you know before we had deniro so
i was like maybe we get to nero back or
maybe we get jack nicholson or you know
somebody great and they're like tom
holland i was like what do you mean
i had to put two and two together i just
realized oh my god you want me for the
old guy but then i realized the benefits
of being in the helicopter barking
orders as opposed to you know having to
be thrown out of a plane or hanging from
a cable for 12 hours a day for six
months
so i i embraced it and it's much better
me kind of playing age-appropriate roles
and imagine me trying to play the 25
year old running around
with a bad back and a bad knee it
wouldn't it wouldn't look good is it
tougher to add weight or lose weight
oh it's much tougher to add weight it's
just it's fun for a week and then you
know i just put put 30 pounds on for a
roll and i'm still feeling uh
it's just still bothering me so i lost
the weight since but it just does a lot
to your body but nothing worse than
being on a full stomach and then having
to eat again it's it's the worst
well that's how you win academy awards
you know when you have the
transformation right you either lose
weight or gain weight
well i think for me if if the roll calls
were i played a guy who was you know
started out as a boxer and then he
became he tried to become an actor and
then after that he wanted to go into the
priesthood after he had a terrible
accident had a visit from under mary
went into the priesthood then he came
down with a rare muscular degenerative
disease ibm and his physicality
basically deteriorated but a
spirituality soared so he had put on a
lot of weight and what was once this
kind of you know really kind of uh
fit guy you know everything just kind of
turned to mush and so you know i had to
you know portray that in an honest way
uh before we let you go let's play the
mark wahlberg bench contest uh we did
this with a lot of guys at the super
bowl one rep max um fritzi what are you
going with wahlberg here i'm gonna go
315. 315. seton going 325. uh marvin
i'm gonna go 285. 285.
paulie three even 300 300 for wahlberg
i'm gonna go
340 max one rep
mark your answer is
dan you're pretty spot on 343.45 has
been my max
um we were we were shooting pain and
gain we would go to the gym and we kind
of do this lift off all the time my
buddy ace who's here
he would go cold turkey right to 3 15
and he'd bet his paycheck every time and
he got squished he got twist every
single time he never lifted it but he
never warmed up i'd go you know 135 for
10 i'd do 185 for 10 i'd do 225 for 10
then i go 315 and then i go you know 340
45. uh but but for that i got labrum
tears in both shoulders
uh hey good luck with the movie great to
talk to you again as always my best to
the family thank you buddy can't wait to
come into the studio and see you guys
thank you thank you that's mark wahlberg
actor uh the new film hits theaters on
friday that's uncharted with uh mr
spider-man tom holland